Leif we truly appreciate your father's work here in Texas
Would you ever consider a career in politics
Well I appreciate that
There's just a deserve. I understand my dad is a US congressman now. He's a freshman US congressman from
Texas district 36 in Southeast, Texas and
I'm very proud of him he
Retired after a career as a small-town dentist you know business
selling this over Army and Air Force Army Army and Air Force veteran
And he was fed up with Washington and didn't like the options that he saw
You know that he knew we're gonna be running for that seat
And he said you know what I'm throwing my hat in the ring. I'm gonna go up there
I'm trying to make a difference and I we need more people like that in Washington
Dad is my dad is there to make a difference and only to make it he doesn't care about a career
He doesn't care about being there for decades and decades and decades
you know he's he's retired, and he'd rather be fishing and hanging out these grandkids and
Hunting but he would but he gives up he cares about the country
And he is sacrificing to be there and to lead and I'm damn proud of the job that he's doing
And stepping up what I consider a career in politics
I can't imagine anything
To be more miserable than that you know what on the other hand when I look at our nation just as my dad
has
As felt, you know call to do that to step up to lead you know if we don't do it who's gonna do it
So somebody's got to step up somebody's got a lead
And I think when you look at the direction of our country right now
And the the the political climate and and all that's going on you know in this electoral cycle
What I do that, maybe I just might be able to be talked into it. Well. We shall see
What about you Joe go get some well. I mean we got we got the bumper stickers, right?
We don't see that go Charles. I think I would be running as if I was to run for political office. I would run as
dictator
And he's a premolar of
America and that's why I said what I would do we could bring back some of the Roman rule to try and triumvirate
So me you and Ecko we could just take take over
I don't know if I have the stomach for politics. I I really don't like
the political arena too much and
Not sure it's something I would ever ever have the desire to do
You know I guess
That's mine. That's where I sit. Maybe when I was 70 years old
Yeah people people have asked me to you know like hey if you were president
What would you do you know about the situation with Iran you know in their development of nuclear weapons or China getting you know?
making big moves in the South China, Sea or Russia pushing the envelope and
And and kind of thumb when their noses at us and often. I've told him that if I were president. I would immediately
Nominate Jaco willing as Secretary of Defense we would change
secretary defense to the previous title of Secretary of War and
And I think those problems would would disappear immediately
I
Think if I was president it'd be very smooth my policy would be pretty simple my policy would be
Kick-ass, that's what we would do
Economic we can you act put your economic plan jaakko kick ass?
But what's your what would you do with this situation over here in the Middle East oh there? Oh, yeah, we're gonna
Do theirs we're gonna kick ass
What about the drug problem that we got coming in through the borders. Oh the the drug cartel
Yeah, we're gonna kick ass on that so that that's my policy. That's like it
So this is why I probably wouldn't be the best politician
They're kind of like DTF yeah anything